>>> 100% REAL AS I SAID ON THE
RADIO YESTERDAY, AND AS I ID
HERE YESTERDAY
IT'S 100% REAL.
>> IN OUR NATIONAL LEAD, SANDY
HOOK HAPPENED, IT'S 100% REAL.
THAT'S THE ADMISSION ALEX JONES
MADE ON THE STAND TODAY, BUT
DOES HE MEAN IT IN THE TRIAL FOR
THE FAR RIGHT CONSPIRACY
THEORIST WILL DETERMINE HOW MUCH
JONES OWNS FOR DEFAMING THE
PARENTS OF A 6-YEAR-OLD AMONG
THE 20 CHILDREN KILLED IN THE
NEWTOWN, CONNECTICUT, SCHOOL
SHOOTING.
JONES ELIS ABOUT THE VICTIMS OF
SANDY HOOK AND THEIR FAMILIES
LED TO YEARS OF HARASSMENT BY
HIS DERANGED FANS.
SOME PARENTS EVEN HAD TO CHANGE
THEIR ADDRESSES.
WE SHOULD NOTE ALEX JONES IS A
FULL-FLEDGED MEMBER OF TEAM
MAGA.
TRUMP WENT ON HIS SHOW IN 2015.
JONES WAS PART OF THE JANUARY
6th INSANITY.
THE JURY COULD BEGIN
DELIBERATING AT ANY MOMENT.
>> Reporter: CON SPEAR SIFT ALEX
JONES FACING REALITY.
QUESTIONED BY THE LAWYER
REPRESENTING THE PARENTS OF
6-YEAR-OLD SANDY HOOK VICTIM.
>> YOU AND YOU COMPANY WANT THE
WORLD TO BELIEVE THIS JUDGE IS
RIGGING THIS COURT PROCEEDING TO
MAKE SURE A SCRIPT, A LITERAL
SCRIPT IS BEING FOLLOWED.
THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT THE WORLD
TO BELIEVE, RIGHT?
>> AREN'T I BARRED FROM TALKING
ABOUT THIS?
>> I'M ASKING THE QUESTION.
>> THE WAY THE COURT WORKS IS
YOU ANSWER A QUESTION UNTIL
THERE'S AN OBJECTION.
>> JONES STRUGGLING TO ANSWER
WITHOUT BEING CONTRADICTED BY
HIS OWN WORDS OR THOSE SAID BY
OTHERS ON HIS BEHALF.
JUST LAST FRIDAY, ROBERT BARNES
FILLED IN FOR JONES ON IS INFO
WAR SHOW.
>> THAT'S WHY THE JUDGE IS
RIGGING THE COURT PROCEEDING TO
MAKE SURE THE SCRIPT, THIS IS
LITERALLY A SCRIPT, A SCRIPT
GETS TOLD IN A CERTAIN WAY FOR
FUTURE AUDIENCES.
>> Reporter: JONES' CROSS
EXAMINATION FOLLOWS WITHERING
TESTIMONY FROM SCARLET LEWIS,
THE MOTHER, SHE FACED DOWN THE
MAN WHO SAID HER SON JESSE NEVER
EXISTED AND HIS MOTHER MERELY AN
ACTRESS.
>> TO HAVE SOMEONE ON TOP OF
THAT PER PET A LIE, A LIE, THAT
IT WAS A HOAX, THAT IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN, IT WAS A FALSE FLAG,
THAT I'M AN ACTRESS.
YOU GET ON AND YOU SAY, OH,
SORRY, BUT I KNOW ACTRESSES WHEN
I SEE THEM.
DO YOU THINK I'M AN ACTRESS?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK I'M AN
ACTRESS.
>> YOU CAN'T TALK RIGHT NOW.
>> Reporter: JONES UNDER
PRESSURE FOUND LIABLE IN THREE
SEPARATE DEFAMATION LAWSUITS
BROUGHT BY THE FAMILIES OF TEN
VICTIMS OF THE SANDY HOOK
MASSACRE.
THE JURY FOR THIS CASE
DETERMINING HOW MUCH JONES MUST
PAY FOR HIS LIES.
>> SANDY HOOK IS A SYNTHETIC,
COMPLETELY FAKE, WITH ACTORS, IN
MY VIEW MANUFACTURED.
>> Reporter: THE PARENTS' LAWYER
ESTABLISHING JONES MADE HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OVER
SEVERAL YEARS BASED ON TEXT
MESSAGES FROM HIS PHONE,
EVIDENCE JONES DIDN'T REALIZES
THEY HAD CATCHING HIM IN ANOTHER
LIE.
>> 12 DAYS AGO, YOUR ATTORNEYS
MESSED UP AND SENT ME AN ENTIRE
DIGITAL COPY OF YOUR ENTIRE CELL
PHONE WITH EVERY TEXT MESSAGE
YOU'VE SENT FOR THE PAST TWO
YEARS, AND WHEN INFORMED, DID
NOT TAKE ANY STEPS TO IDENTIFY
IT AS PRIVILEGED OR PROTECTED IN
ANY WAY.
AS OF TWO DAYS AGO, IT FELL FREE
AND CLEAR INTO MY POSSESSION,
AND THAT IS HOW I KNOW YOU LIED
TO ME WHEN YOU SAID YOU DIDN'T
HAVE TEXT MESSAGES ABOUT SANDY
HOOK.
DID YOU KNOW THAT?
>> I TOLD YOU THE TRUTH.
THIS IS YOUR PERRY MASON MOMENT.
I GAVE THEM MY PHONE.
>> Reporter: JONES TESTIFIED
EARLIER IN A DEPOSITION THAT HE
SEARCHED THE TEXT MESSAGES ON
HIS PHONE FOR THE TERM SANDY
HOOK, AND IT CAME BACK WITH NO
HITS.
>> I HAD SEVERAL DIFFERENT
PHONES WITH THIS NUMBER, BUT I
DID, YEAH.
THAT'S WHY YOU GOT IT.
>> NO, MR. JONES.
THAT'S NOT WHY I HAVE IT.
>> MY LAWYER SENT IT TO YOU, BUT
I'M HIDING IT.
OKAY.
>> MR. JONES, PLEASE JUST ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
>> Reporter: JONES' DEFENSE, ON
HIS SHOW HE'S ONLY ASKING
QUESTIONS AND THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA IS TAKING EVERYTHING HE
SAYS OUT OF CONTEXT.
THE FAMILY OF JESSE LEWIS ARE
ASKING UP TO $150 MILLION IN
DAMAGES.
THE DEFENSE LAWYERS FOR MR.
JONES ARE DOING THEIR CLOSING
ARGUMENTS RIGHT NOW.
WE EXPECT A JURY MAY HAVE THIS
CASE ANY TIME THIS AFTERNOON,
AND THEN IT WILL BE IN THEIR
HANDS TO DECIDE WHAT HE'S LIABLE
FOR.
JAKE.
>> MIGUEL, IF THE JURY DECIDES
TO AWARD A LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY
TO THE FAMILY, WHAT'S THE CHANCE
THAT THE PARENTS WILL ACTUALLY
SEE THE MONEY?
>> THAT IS ALREADY A GROWING
QUESTION, NOT ONLY THIS FAMILY
BUT OTHERS.
REMEMBER, THERE ARE THREE
DIFFERENT DEFAMATION CASES HE'S
NOW BEEN HELD LIABLE FOR OR HE'S
LIABLE IN.
THE FAMILIES ARE CONCERNED THAT
HE'S USING BANKRUPTCY LAWS TO
HIDE TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN PROFITS IN ORDER TO KEEP IT